.
LET'S GET STARTED.
WE BEGIN WITH THIS.
MONDAY THE NATION WILL
COMMEMORATE LABOR DAY.
AND THE LABOR OF HARD WORKING
AMERICANS.
BUT WITH MID-TERMS 66 DAYS AWAY,
THERE IS NO BIGGER STORY THAN
THE ECONOMY.
71% OF YOU AREN'T SEEING ANY
SIGNS OF REBOUND.
MORE AND MORE DEMOCRATS AND
INDEPENDENTS SAY THE SAME THING.
WHY WOULD THAT BE?
BECAUSE THEIR WALLETS ARE
LIGHTER AND THEY ARE TAKING A
HIT.
THE PRICE OF GAS STILL UP 20%.
GROCERIES SKYROCKETING 13%.
AND TO TOP IT OFF, WE ARE NOT
ABLE TO FILL ENOUGH JOBS TO STOP
SUPPLY CHAIN DISRUPTION.
SERVICE AT FAST FOOD RESTAURANTS
NOT EVEN CLOSE TO WHERE IT WAS.
THE CHAOS ON AIRLINES, THE
DELAYS, THE CANCELLATIONS, WE
ALL EXPERIENCED THEM.